hello everyone and welcome to the next
generation of software developers panel
i'm danae forda robinson a senior
researcher at microsoft research redmond
where i lead a project here geared at
supporting pathways and opportunities
for the next generation of software
developers so today i have the distinct
pleasure of being the moderator for
today's panel with amazing thoughts and
action leaders in thinking about this
landscape
i'm joined by mala kumar who is the
director of tech for social good at
github
margaret price who is a principal
strategist for cs education at microsoft
and bobby dresser who is the director of
product for the community team at github
welcome to the panelists and thank you
so much for joining us for the summit
today
so this panel will cover two core themes
which are first what is the next
generation of software developers as in
what would they include and why it's
important to think of this
and theme number two which is how do we
make sure the next generation of
developers succeed
so without further ado let's get started
so to kick off this panel i would like
to give each of you the floor to say a
few words about an exciting project
you're currently working on and where
you may see that fitting into your own
personal definition of the next
generation of developers so you have the
opportunity to define whatever that
means for each of you
um mala would you like to go first
sure i hope everybody can hear me all
right so again my name is mal i'm the
director of tech for social good and
what we do at github is basically fold
in everything to do with the social
sector so these are non-profit
organizations the united nations and
other organizations some including
for-profit that basically work on
something to do with the sustainable
development goals and really advance
human development so that's really our
focus and a lot of our work is on open
source capacity within these
organizations and just what it means to
basically mean make tech more equitable
and work for everybody better
so some of the work that we're doing now
that i'm especially interested and proud
of is research
coming from a field called tech for
international development where i spent
most of my career with the united
nations i can tell you that one of the
things that and i'm sure danae knows
this because we've had
many many conversations about this is
there's just a lack of research out
there about how tech influences the
world and how we can use it for for good
um kind of a anecdote that i always give
is that there's probably more research
about toilet paper and paper towels than
there are about the education system and
technology for most countries in
sub-saharan africa so anything that we
can do to kind of augment that research
is super important and so to that aim we
did a research project a couple years
ago that focuses on open source and the
social sector and just what exactly that
means who's doing what and then we're
doing a follow-on project now
focusing on four low and middle income
countries which are kenya egypt india
and mexico to kind of get the landscape
of how these developer communities are
working on github what they're building
why they care and how we can better
engage them in the future so i think
that's going to yield a lot of really
great insights and excited to talk more
about that during this panel
awesome margaret didn't go next
yeah thanks denae it's good to be here
so
i was hired into microsoft as one of the
founders of the inclusive design
practice which is a method for creation
that embodies the full range of human
diversity to build equitable experiences
for the widest number of people
and so i've spent a lot of time applying
this to a range of products and services
in and outside of microsoft as well as
partnering really closely with
nonprofits who want to solve some of the
most wicked problems that exist in the
world today
so one of the big problems i'm focused
on right now is looking at the crisis of
computer science education and the
skills gap
so some of the problems that exist in
the landscape are of course that there
are many more jobs available than there
are people to fill those jobs and that
even the people who are currently
learning cs while there are many there
are up to three times the number of
students that want to take computer
science and higher education than there
are available professors to teach them
we have a huge dropout rates up to 80
percent of minority students drop out of
their intro classes in higher ed we have
k through 12 students around the world
who are still not exposed to computer
science so one of the big questions that
i seek to answer through research
programs partnerships and product is how
can we best prepare the next generation
for jobs of tomorrow and what does that
really look like
awesome i love this next generation for
tomorrow
um very campaigny bobby do you want to
go next
sure thanks denay um margaret and mala
super interesting to hear about this
project and i'm excited to chat more
about them uh as denae mentioned i'm
bobby i work at github on the
communities team and our group thinks a
lot about how to empower open source
communities to attract new contributors
to participate meaningfully with them in
a way that is productive and helps them
meet their goals and then also about how
open source communities can sustain and
create sort of rewarding environments
that encourage people to continue to
participate
and one of the one of the projects i'm
particularly excited about in that broad
umbrella is this piece around discovery
and helping people on github both
discover new projects that either
inspire them or educate them or connect
them with some new piece of technology
or new piece of infrastructure that they
haven't previously encountered and on
the flip side how we give creators on
github more
opportunities for encouragement more
opportunities to sort of grow their
communities or
grow their audience or their their
sponsorship
fan base if that's something that
they're looking for i'm sort of
connecting both sides of this
marketplace so that the incredible work
that happens across the globe on github
from millions and millions of developers
has a easier time kind of finding its
audience and creating ideally this
positive some feedback loop that can
inspire people to become creators and
help creators kind of continue on on
their journey to wherever they want to
go and so there's a lot in there but
it's um it's a very exciting problem to
break off because i think it it creates
a lot of opportunity for people in a lot
of different um situations
for sure
okay so this is a great i'm glad i let
you guys do a round of intros because i
think a lot of this kind of goes into
the next question i had about criteria
so i heard things about engagement
empowerment there's marginalized
perspectives even from the global
perspective and in the us context as
well
can you all talk a little bit about
maybe the criteria or the
characterization that you all have in
mind when you're thinking about the next
generation of developers and what that
looks like in in your context or even
beyond
anyone can get started
i can jump in so
i think a lot about
students and how increasingly
undergraduate and k-12 programs are
being called upon to prepare
a much larger and much more diverse
population of folks in careers both in
and outside of computer science and so
many of these students want
understandings and competencies
needed to learn how to use computation
collaboratively across different
contexts and challenging problems often
to make a difference in the world
and so shifting language
from developer for a lot of these
students is really important a lot of
them don't self-identify and don't want
to self-identify as developers they want
to be creators with technology to do
something good in the world
and so
i often think a lot about what it means
to build for
folks who want to learn technology as a
core criteria
whether they're majoring in computer
science or not
like this creators creators of
technology
molly were you also going to add
something as well
yeah i think a lot of it has to do with
margaret it was saying what she was
saying so i think you know the
classification i already is a really
tough thing so i prior to working
at github i joined about two and a half
years ago i spent the majority of my
career at the un and so nobody would
ever classify me as a technologist even
though i built products that the u.n
would then deploy around the world and
ironically i github i don't work
directly on the product so it's almost
like a role reversal but i would only be
classified as a proper technologist by a
lot of people from the last couple of
years so i think just you know being
more flexible in the terminology and
recognizing that tech is pervasive in
basically everything we do and that's
really the case across the world so the
adoption may be different the use cases
may be different the mental models are
definitely different and we can talk
about that more in a second
but the orientation around tech is
increasing globally and i think that's
you know a trend that we have to
recognize so we need to be a bit more
cautious about how we use those words
but also flexible at the same time so
the grand irony of the situation
um
i think another thing to just keep in
mind is there is no specific definition
of developer it's kind of like the word
scientist you know it's like what
exactly does that mean
so a lot of the work that we do on
github is on text files but that doesn't
mean that we're not using the platform
in similar ways as somebody who's
writing code it just means that maybe
somebody's a better writer than they are
at writing syntax in the language
so i think you know the ways that we use
technology are also a bit nefarious not
nefarious but just ambiguous in the way
that we would classify it so i think
going forward being more open and what
developer means but then also
recognizing as margaret said that the
word doesn't necessarily resonate like i
don't know that many people in the
social sector that would call themselves
developers but they write code or maybe
they interact with code or maybe they're
a data scientist but they wouldn't call
themselves that either so the
terminologies are a bit fuzzy i'd say
yeah i would second that i think before
and i've probably had the conversation
maybe with all of you at one point was i
was using this phrase called like
programmers for a purpose
um
just trying to figure out different ways
to broaden people who use
programming or coding for a task
specifically but they may not like you
said call themselves developers
bobby do you have a perspective to share
as well
yeah i agree with both of uh what mala
and margaret said i think that the
cohort of folks who belong in the next
generation of developers is just
strictly broader than what we have today
and i think that's a really exciting
thing for a variety of reasons so
education is a huge piece of that like
there are there are
uh somewhere around the order of 55 to
65 percent of new users to github at
least the ones who fill out this little
new user onboarding survey um say that
they have little to no programming
experience at all and so when we think
about people who are walking in the
front door there's this like
overwhelming mass of folks who
are expressing interest just by the act
that they are taking of signing up for a
github account and they are starting
from scratch or close to it and so
there's a huge set of really important
questions and i'm glad margaret is
thinking about them around how we
help people get from zero to one and the
sort of distribution of that opportunity
at the same time github has some
programs like the
global campus ambassadors program sort
of
these programs that attach to
educational environments around the
world and help
teachers and students use github for
some of their
like classwork and things like that and
so we see this as a nice hands-on way to
get up and running and actually open
people's eyes to the way that
programming and development can be super
collaborative because the solo journey i
think is very different from the
interconnected journey and i think
that's an interesting touch point in
this definition of the next generation
as well like it's not necessarily
someone sitting alone and making
something by themselves there are so
many building blocks that already exist
and there are so many resources out
there so in many ways this next chapter
is about like assembling all of those
things whether they are educational
resources or whether they're actual
tools and pieces of infrastructure like
putting those together to achieve some
set of goals
and then i love mala what you mentioned
at the end like
uh development is
less and less just about pure sort of
software and and web development and
more and more about
science and analysis and social work and
city planning and all of these things
that um more and more like require
technical skills and oftentimes get
people to a place where they have to
program to do their job or do something
at scale
and i think that's a huge part of what
this next generation is about moving
away from what we think of as software
development like little things that
we're moving around our web browsers or
our desktop applications and getting to
a place where
programming is baked into so many
different disciplines and so it's less
of a niche and more of like a sort of
foundational requirement for a lot of
different folks doing a lot of different
things
um this manifests on github as well in a
variety of ways like we recently
launched the ability to
add a citation file to a github repo
because so many repositories or data
sets are required to be cited or at
least there's demand for them to be
cited in like published academic work
and so we think about the people who are
using our platform not just as
programmers but as people doing a whole
bunch of things where programming is
just one one little ingredient
yes i was actually going to add that so
that's actually perfect for that because
i think i think a lot of what i'm
hearing is also about different forms of
collaborations that are taking place and
where they're happening so like when
you're thinking about github and
platform like a lot of scientists or
data scientists are using those
resources as places to host information
um so like in ways like programming or
technical contribution as a way
through science um
something to think deeper about but what
i was going to ask actually was um how
would you say the work that you're doing
here at microsoft or github
how has it been pivotal uh or how has it
pivoted in a way in anticipation for the
next generation
yeah i mean so some of the work that we
do
is with the world health organization so
you know in response to covet honestly
i live in new york city so cases started
to spike here in march 2020 and so we
ended up entering into an agreement to
support the world health organization
through a pretty you know large
contribution but more than the
contribution was the collaboration that
came out of it through our professional
services team and then through
my team with tech for social good
and so one of the things that we're
always thinking about is how to make
open source more equitable how to make
github more equitable and a lot of that
i think is through the geography of it
so we see the adoption in different
countries for different segments of the
population but really looking for it and
this probably gets into your next few
questions is what is the next generation
and that very much is a geographic
divide but then it's also very specific
cases so for instance you know we have
more capacity through github on our
mobile app than we ever have had before
and a lot of people have a mental model
and orientation around mobile first so
they can't interact on mobile they're
probably not going to do it
and so just having those options out
there makes it more possible for more
people in different countries in low and
middle income countries especially
throughout sub-saharan africa to
interact with these
you know platforms um but by the same
token a lot of things are moving to
cloud only and so you need to have a
base level of infrastructure to be able
to access that in the first place so we
have a bit of a conundrum there but i do
think one of the things that we're just
anticipating is that there's going to be
a lot more people from sub-saharan
africa parts of south asia and latin
america in urban areas that have a base
level of literacy understand kind of at
a high level how technology might impact
them and then also see more career
opportunities and i think you know
organizations like the world health
organization that employ a lot of
african developers is exactly one of the
areas that we're trying to work with so
it was not just in response to the
public health catastrophe but also
what's going to happen in the next
generation anyway
i love that there's the prac there's
something that i actually had another
question for later about impact and i
feel like for what i'm hearing part of
planning for the next generation is
being able to pivot and when there's
needs being able to fulfill them or do
your part to have the resources that you
have and being able to make a difference
in technology in that way and i think a
lot of developers are also interested in
that as well
um being able to shift and use their
needs you know where society needs them
yeah absolutely i mean collaboration has
been a cornerstone of public health for
oh you know 50 60 years so the fact that
we just have the right people in the
right place and were able to get the
right product to the right team was
really pivotal and that's exactly the
kind of impact that we try to identify
in any emergency but in even anything
that's ongoing
for sure for sure margaret did you want
to talk about one of your kind of pivot
projects or how did any of your products
be sure so we spend a lot of time
working with diverse cohorts of students
professors and teachers to really deeply
understand and meet their needs in a
holistic way and i think that's a big
pivot away from how
um you know only focusing on product to
really focusing on
uh holistic need sets so of course on
the product side we look at things like
how to make starting and onboarding in
vs code as easy and simple as possible
for students who want to learn
professional tools but feel that they're
way too complex so we've actually just
launched you know vs code extension for
github classroom to really help think
about how these things can interconnect
and so there's a lot more product work
involved
outside of product we've really looked
at some of the core skills that are
essential in addition to learning to
code they're not being taught today so
things like starting a mentoring program
that teaches tech resilience to students
where we've touched a couple of thousand
folks who've said gosh i was gonna drop
out and now i'm not because i learned
the core skills like growth mindset
and resilience and self-efficacy to help
me persist in this program and so
learning that need about why students
are dropping out of course there are
multiple reasons that are
multi-dimensional
but one of them was right a lack of
mentors and a lack of learning some of
the essential skills
that can help you pivot and not panic
when faced in difficulty
the third area is really programmatic uh
partnerships so we look at partnering
with nonprofits and big companies all
around the world to help
this mission uh so you might be you know
partnering with warner brothers or
netflix or lebron james to launch custom
curricula or challenges or hackathons to
get the next generation really excited
one big piece of feedback they gave was
hey
the curricula is kind of boring that's
online we want something that's
connected to solving real world problems
we want something that's exciting that's
relevant to brands that we care about
today so we're always looking for
those perspectives to help build this
holistic strategy because of course
product is not enough so we really need
to look at how we can support learner
success and break a lot of the existing
barriers and so i know we'll get in a
little bit later to some of the skills
that need to be learned and so i can
talk more about that then
i love that you brought up sort of the
the retention rate of folks who have
started down an education path and then
drop off for a variety of reasons um our
team has thought about some really
similar challenges and i think it's core
to what what it means to help this next
generation actually be successful so i
mentioned the stats for new users
joining github and we sort of noticed
that and used it as a launch pad to
reimagine the sign up experience when
you go to create a github.com account
i'm taking it from like a very standard
basic form to something that's a little
bit more compelling and helps people
feel like they're taking their first
steps towards understanding what they
came to github to learn
and obviously there's there's a long
ways to go and it comes back to some of
the earlier points i made around
discovery and helping match people with
the right contribution opportunity or
the right getting started project or the
right
set of resources to make sure that they
can go from zero to one but there's a
lot of interesting challenges there and
that's
at least one recent example of how our
team's work has pivoted to help empower
the next generation
and then i also mentioned open source
like open source is not new but it
certainly has gone through a variety of
culture shifts over the past several
decades
and one thing we're very conscious of
going forward is
how to a keep open source
um
happening and not just happening but
making it uh much much stronger in terms
of
a viable career path for folks something
that people of any type of background
can actually look at and say this is
something that i could do and it also
has the potential to sustain me as a
full-time job and as if we look at the
past 15 years or so oftentimes open
source is limited to folks who have
nights and weekends to spend or who are
employed by a large tech company and can
use some of their working hours to
participate in open source and we want
to really get this to a place where
working full-time on an open source
project is this actual career path that
people see and pursue and is a way for
them to work full-time for themselves or
full-time for the internet and really
give away a piece of software that
becomes a building block
and so that to me is a key piece of this
next future transitioning open source
from
just an option for folks who have the
luxury of extra time and extra bandwidth
to a place where it is sustainable and
rewarding for anyone who has the skills
and capacity and interest to making it
happen and that's a lot of the rationale
and thinking behind github sponsors
which is in its second year and um
continues to grow really tremendously
and obviously has a long way until this
opportunity is evenly distributed like
we're live in 34 countries and wish we
were live in in 200 so there's certainly
a lot of work cut out for us but um
making baby steps towards that that end
goal i think is a another really
important ingredient in helping this
next generation succeed
oh for sure i actually enjoy how all of
you mentioned kind of expanding or
broadening the scope of how the products
you work on can reach and but with
broadening the scopes kind of introduces
like broader and bigger challenges and
issues and i know we have a bunch of
academic researchers practitioners
people in industry watching as well and
i'm a strong proponent of like the more
heads we have on our problem the more
creative solutions we can come up with
to solve them so i'm curious if you all
could share what are some of the biggest
challenges
or
biggest needs the gaps that you think we
need or we have that we need to fill to
support the next generation
yeah one of the
fascinating things continuing this
threat of open source participation is
this mismatch between sort of
contributor energy and maintainer
bandwidth where
oftentimes the
core challenge of an open source project
isn't that there aren't enough people
who want to help it's the coordination
challenge of taking that potential
energy and applying it to the right set
of problems and oftentimes that burden
ends up entirely on the maintainer to
say here are these issues that are ready
for someone and let me answer these 200
questions so that this set of people can
get up and running and and like the
quality of the people walking in the
door is a really important ingredient in
making sure that that
project ends up being successful so
we've invested pretty substantially over
the past couple months and a new feature
for github called discussions which
is a companion to the issues that folks
might be familiar with on a github
repository and really gives contributors
a place to show up and ask open-ended
questions and those could range from hey
this project is interesting how do i get
set up to have you thought about
this very specific feature request to
hey i think the contributing guidelines
need to be updated because x y and z so
it really i think gives the community a
place to gather and discuss things with
a little bit more depth and context and
nuance than issues which are
traditionally focused around getting
something done or filing a bug
and then the sort of medical is to
create this place where the community
can help each other rather than having
all of that fall on the maintainers
shoulders um and so and this is like a
our hypothesis is that this will help
open source communities scale beyond
just requiring the maintainers energy
and attention for every sort of
incremental bit of progress can really
help itself thrive and scale to a new
level and in doing so becomes ideally
much more comfortable and open to
newcomers folks who might not know as
much and don't have to open an issue
which is like baked into its name
something is wrong like this is an issue
and really carves out an explicit space
to say hey i'm new does anyone have a
moment to help me out or hey i'm having
trouble getting set up or i don't
understand how to apply this library to
x y and z um and kind of opening the
door and making sure that that type of
participation that type of curiosity is
celebrated on github and not sort of
pushed to the margins and so hopefully
that that's like a step and again with
all of these things there's a lot to go
but we're excited to see that take off
and um
chip away at making open source a little
bit more welcoming to newcomers
i think um one of the things that bobby
mentioned is something that's been on my
mind for two and a half years now is
discovery
one of the first insights that we
gathered from our research on open
source in the social sector so the
report that we published back in april
2020 and the research we started in
april
2019 was that especially in the social
sector and this makes sense people don't
necessarily galvanize around the
technology solution like they don't care
about if somebody's writing something in
r or in python um they don't care about
it this is on this stack what they care
about is a cause right they care about
bettering the world around them they
care about making sure that people have
more equitable access that human
development progresses and so
discoverability is like a
disproportionate challenge in the social
sector for people who are searching by
keywords or for organizations for people
who kind of need that reinforcement to
understand what's already out there and
so i think one one of the things that we
can do at github and then hopefully you
know the tech sector at large it's just
making technology more searchable by
causes the things that people actually
care about
i think another thing that we've
invested a lot in tech for social good
is the community building aspect so we
actually recently launched a website for
a monitoring and evaluation community
called the mural center and so everybody
collaborates on github we staged a
github page's site so that their content
is accessible by other people who don't
want to necessarily interact with the
platform but it's basically all text
based at this point might progress to
some code if somebody wants to add a
script in for example for a data clean
but it's working in a i think a pretty
creative way but also habitualizing
people to the platform and it's a great
example because more than a quarter of
our members are women of color and we
have quite a few people from sub-saharan
africa participating so just thinking
about the exact same contribution that
they can put in a word document or in a
google doc on github just you know again
orients them to the platform and
hopefully opens the door for something
maybe more depth in the future
and to build on i completely agree uh
everything you're saying i guess yes yes
you know the exposure
and the different layers of exposure and
discovery from
um i can learn a set of skills to i
understand how i can apply these skills
to i understand what career is feasible
and possible as a direct result of
learning these skills
and so we're thinking a lot about those
different layers and how we can help so
as an example
looking at a lot of the industries that
are hiring for these skills maybe that's
healthcare as an example so what would
it mean to provide
the
curricula that is grounded in solving
real world healthcare problems to make
social impact the career pathways what
would it mean to provide a series of
videos for people who were already
working in these jobs and how did they
get there and what was their journey and
what was their path
and
you know in addition to kind of the
exposure we're looking a lot at those
dropout rates because of course the
direct uh result is a less diverse
workforce so
we know that far too many talented
people either actively avoid or choose
to leave whether that's middle school
high school college or college to career
tech fields because of perceptions and
realities of negative cultures so what
does it mean to invest in the core
preparation of students whether in
computer science engineering or other
fields to take agency and ownership over
tech pathways that could dramatically
shift the climate in tech and
investing in the training of current
employees in tech spaces to help shift
the culture such that when these
students get hired and start their jobs
they can feel a sense of inclusion and
belonging and so we're doing a lot of
work in that space as well
and the third kind of challenge to your
question today that we're looking at
solving is
you know how we can
you know solve the kind of educator
capacity crisis so we know that there
are so many educators that are over
subscribed and we want to help so what
does that mean in terms of providing
more support
and also more curricula for students so
that we can help them directly
i i love how you talked about how we can
help them directly because my i actually
wanted to pivot to our second theme a
bit now um which is how do we make sure
the next generation succeeds
um and my my first question we have in
that perspective is you know what can we
do now what should we be doing now in
our work and our research projects to
best create an environment where people
cannot just succeed but thrive so i want
to you know clarify that there's a
distinction between there how do we help
people kind of like
over like overreach and attract their
dreams or kind of reach their dreams and
their goals i wonder if you all thought
about that at all
yeah so from our side um
you know we thought a lot about needing
a way for students to gain core skills
and for professionals already working in
this space to continue practicing
developing and adapting their knowledge
in a way that's customized for them on
their career path
and so we've spent a lot of time
building a research-based toolkit
involving core psychology you know
psychology education and team-based
concepts to look at how do we
situate scenarios and strategies in a
way that's directly relevant teaching
some of this core skills that students
don't graduate with and that create huge
cyclical problems in the workplace so as
an example how people learn to overcome
obstacles they encounter how effective
teams are constructed how to gauge group
dynamics in hybrid remote
or in-person environments how to
navigate conflict how people can
contribute to environments around them
to make them more or less inclusive and
there are surely more of course but the
reality is only a small subset of
students are opting to take courses in
organizational behavior or leadership
and only a small subset of employees are
opting to take leadership courses and so
we're thinking a lot about and launching
sets of curricula to to help kind of
solve this but certainly a lot more
research and time is needed to really
think through
uh these barriers both on the student
side and ensuring that they're learning
skills like growth mindset resilience
self-regulation emotional intelligence
and more and that those core skills are
also taught to folks in industry so that
to your point it's not just succeed but
thrive and making sure that people have
the skills and the abilities to really
think about what does thriving mean and
how to create sense of belongingness for
yourself and for all those around you
and so we have a mentoring program
instead of curricula targeting both
students and professionals
and there's still so much work
to be done in that space
it's really wonderful to hear about some
of this research that you're doing
margaret it um i think these are
really
nuanced problems especially some of
these
public
forums for collaboration among anyone
who walks in off the internet and wants
to like
jump in and start coding with each other
there are really nuanced social dynamics
and pretty sort of gnarly ways that
participation can go wrong and really
tremendous ways that it can go right and
one of the keys i think to designing
solutions that actually work for the the
right set of folks this like inclusive
and broad definition of whatever the
next generation
counts as
includes research and so we've had the
pleasure of working directly with danae
over the past several months to actually
understand
how some of these problems manifest and
how our different solutions can be
validated or invalidated from folks with
different backgrounds like there's i
think a tendency in fast-paced product
development to jump to a solution and
deliver something to your users as
quickly as possible and i can't
overstate enough how helpful some of
today's research has been in setting a
foundation
and orienting us towards a set of
solutions that
have the right sort of texture and
context and framing so that they work
for
um like work for these these dynamics
that otherwise we might back ourselves
into a corner with so um research is
crucial and um taking the time to
actually understand the problem space
and back that up as much as possible
with real input from the folks that
you're solving for i think is is is a is
a crucial ingredient in making this
happen
and the second thing i'll mention is
like definitions so i mentioned the
difference between the word issue and
the word discussion earlier on and i
love that you're pressing us on like
trying to define what this next
generation of developers looks like
because that also sort of sets the
parameters for what we even consider
building and repositioning even what
github thinks it's about from people
building
websites and people doing specific
software development together or people
building open source frameworks to a
place where any
text file can exist any piece of code
any sort of large project with a bunch
of tendrils can exist that could be
applied in any possible discipline i
think is a shift in the way that we
think about building for our users it
acknowledges not just users one two and
three but also users four through ten
who might be a different age and from a
different country and have a very
different sort of baseline understanding
for how to interact with some sort of
web-based product as mala mentioned
earlier like even having something like
a mobile app is a totally different um
partner in some of the stuff and
delivering value to folks so making sure
we're careful about defining what we are
aiming towards and defining
as broadly as possible the set of folks
that we're trying to solve these
problems for um both of those things are
are deeply important i think
um i think yeah i echo the comments that
bobby and margaret made i think one of
the challenges that we're always facing
especially being a relatively small team
is
just directing that energy and
productivity into the correct channels
um you know when covet started to spike
here in the states the number of
activities that we saw that had been
tagged you know the repositories that
have been tagged in public health or
even who even if it wasn't an official
repository of the organization it spiked
it went up people wanted to say how can
i use my tech in order to you know solve
coven and i think unfortunately that
reductive reasoning is part of the issue
that we have in the industry because we
use this term solving problems as though
problems are simple and can be solved
directly through technology sometimes
tech is very very small
as part of the solution right
it's increasingly important and that's
why we're all here but we have to
recognize that the policies the
structures the systemic racism or
whatever the underlying issues that
we're dealing with are really the reason
why we're in the position that we are
and so we have to recognize where the
tech can be directed and what exactly it
can do in order to make you know to move
the needle in the correct direction
and so
you know back to that example with the
world health organization you know if i
i just imagine so many times like what
if we had been able to take all of those
developers and just say
chill and just let us help you find the
best place to plug in the best place to
use your skills because who has a lot of
needs they're building a lot of tools
there's a lot of organizations that have
been working on these public health
issues with infectious diseases for 20
30 years they need your help but we need
to figure out how we can actually make
sure that your contributions make sense
instead of trying to build an app that's
going to magically you know resolve
covet
and that's something that only comes
with experience you know once you're
based in whichever country in
sub-saharan africa working for the un i
can say from experience you realize how
complicated these things really are
and so i think one simple thing that
tech companies can do is just to hire
more people from these fields you know
there's a lot of international
development practitioners like me who
are deeply oriented into tech that can
come in and make valuable contributions
and i know microsoft's done that github
did that with hiring me
and that just helps you identify
opportunities and you know margaret
mentioned her mentor program we have
something similar through skills-based
volunteering we hired a program manager
cynthia who leads that exact work so she
works with social sector organizations
like the un to identify specific need
hooks them up with the github staff and
then those people solve that specific
issue together and so then all of a
sudden you've got github staff to
understand that wow my skills are really
valuable for this specific thing and
this thing is going to help something in
the world and then wha staff or
whichever organization at the un
understands the depth of their technical
ask and so that kind of exchange i think
is really
important and it's valuable and github
is the kind of company that can really
facilitate that through our platform
with the openness and transparency that
we have
and so i think if we just invest more
research and time into figuring out like
more sustainable solutions and how to
scale those kind of solutions for that
direct collaboration
whether it's within different countries
or people of different socioeconomic
classes or races or whatever that
exchange may be
there's a lot that we can do on the
existing technology instead of trying to
reinvent that tech piece i think we need
to get better at how we actually use it
yes
yes to all of that
um i'm so glad i was on mute and i was
listening to my sermon
i'm
here for it um so you only have a few
more minutes left and this is actually i
may be a great point to end on and molly
your point about kind of moving the
needle or how people figure out what
talk now before figuring out what
technology to build is figure out what
are the challenges and expertise that
already exist in this space
and then have them sit in the room where
the experts in that space are and then
you can build a tech to make it work
i may be priming heavily here so i
apologize but i'm curious if you all are
anticipating a shift in our technical
culture um of like do you see that there
will be a shift where we're listening to
the experts the technical experts who
are not
coding or not software engineers are we
seeing a shift where we're focusing on
their perspective first and using their
strategic consultants in a way and i'm
curious if maybe i'm just biased because
the the work that i'm doing and the
participants that i'm talking to my
studies but i'm curious as what this
looks like for you all especially as
you're working in different settings
margaret in the classroom in different
types of not just k-12 environments with
people with different ranges of skills
are you seeing something similar or are
you anticipating something similar
yes
um i think
you know we're unfortunately we're still
in the middle of copen that's the only
way to phrase it right like we all
thought that i think a lot of us thought
that cobit would have abated largely by
now but it's continuing continuing to
rage on and we're seeing new variants
and so
a lot of the you know from an emergency
perspective a lot of the lessons learned
can only come in hindsight so i'm sure
we'll know more in the coming years i do
think kobit was transformational in a
lot of ways and i think part of that is
just
it's salient on a lot more people's
minds of how far into
issues like climate change and natural
disasters and all of the things that
come with the new world order how how
deep we are and how much we have to do
with that so
i am hoping that our attention and our
funding will go more to these you know
underlying issues so that we can become
more resilient as a global society
so hopefully i think again from the
cause area we'll see some change in how
tech is applied and what people
prioritize
i completely agree with everything that
was just said i think
you know from the student angle we see
that shift in what's being taught to
whom
and
you know students asking consistently
for
learning not only the tech skills but
the problem finding and framing skills
to your earlier point about you know
it's not just applying technology but
but where and how
can you contribute your skills in a
meaningful way and being able to
take a step back and really think
through you know what does that look
like how do you find the right
opportunities how do you frame those
opportunities how do you work with
diverse skill sets of people who
have
an understanding of how to do research
how to design
how to plug into social structures
and many many many more and so i think
the
demand for those interdisciplinary
skills is increasing
to to your point and so i think because
we're seeing that we'll continue with
those skills as students graduate and
enter the workforce and in their uh
learning environments look for projects
to make impact on we'll continue to see
that shift happening
yeah i
i also see an experience and am hopeful
for this sort of tectonic shift i don't
know that it will be brought about by
folks paying more attention to experts
like when i think about the next
generation of developers i think about
permissionless innovation happening
across the globe with
increasingly sophisticated building
blocks which is i think a core part of
it
a developer who's learning to program
today might be using copilot when
20 years ago i don't know in a
university computer science course
they're writing everything in c and so
the
actual starting point is a moving target
and becomes more and more sophisticated
which is like a really empowering launch
pad and the cool part is that a lot of
those
increasingly sophisticated building
blocks not all of them granted but more
and more of them are
freely available to lots of different
people like software development today
is easier and more robust than it was
20 or 30 years ago and is also cheaper
um and so that means a lot of lovely
things and i i think this is there's
sort of like a
balancing cultural force where this is
somewhat anecdotal but i think in a lot
of ways that the youth so to speak are
increasingly socially aware they're
inheriting a broken planet they are um
very sort of connected with other folks
around the world for better or for worse
and so i i think applying some of these
challenges of
the life ahead of them and trying to
address them through software
development is an interesting
sort of marriage and we see fun things
like people
increasingly fan personing over nasa's
recent launches and how that sort of
like ripples across github or some of
this open insulin hacking that happens
on github and creates quite a splash
just basically applying these
sophisticated building blocks to a whole
set of challenges beyond again what we
are used to and um sort of open-ended
pointing towards the future
um
and so that's very exciting i think it's
like it's hard to say where it will go i
don't know that people who are in
positions of expertise will be consulted
perhaps as much as they should be like
it's often a shame how much knowledge
and experience gets built up and then
someone trying to solve a problem like
recreates the wheel like it sounds like
molly you experienced something similar
with the like frenzy of um
of
like valid and celebrated uh positive
action
after covid but potentially like uh
disjointed and when reality it could be
nice to all listen to a person who knows
what they're talking about that thing
might happen again but hopefully it is
more um evenly available and folks from
different backgrounds can participate
and solve these problems the way that
they want to solve i have no idea what
that will look like but i'm excited i'm
excited to see
yes it sounds like a discovery discovery
issue part two which is like okay
there's experts do you do the people
building technology familiar with where
the exports resources are where they
have shared that knowledge how to reach
them so that's like an additional layer
every time yeah over here
yeah
yeah i think it's you know it's two-fold
i think organizations are becoming more
open and i think it's largely because of
the work that githubs and microsoft's
are doing so that culture change is
really important like margaret talked
about the organizational management
piece and that's
huge it's not you know
the most desired talked about thing in
tech but it's really important sometimes
and so i think on one side you're seeing
that but then on the other side we do
have to figure out how can we take that
excitement and that momentum that
bobby's talking about through you know
the breakdown of barriers especially
with learning how to code or putting
something out there for the world to see
and just channel it into more productive
ways especially when it comes to these
causes where
you know 10 hours of lost time is a big
deal you know
yeah
well with that um we're gonna end the
panel there um thank you all so much for
joining us today
um i wish everyone was here in the room
this week i'll clap for the panelists
but i'll clap for my for you all myself
um it's been a pleasure getting to work
with you all even in passing have
amazing conversations about research
problems and i'm just glad we were able
to do that on a public stage for people
to hear
um
so
thank you all and and i guess that's it
so we can have a great day
thanks today thanks margaret thanks
molly and thank you bye everyone bye